über 33.000 Euro
und hätte man damals in Bitcoin
investiert während es über 80 Millionen
hätte hätte Fahrradkette heute ist es
soweit ich möchte endlich mein erstes
großes Investment tätigen insgesamt will
ich 40.000 € ausgeben woran ich das
investiere wie sich das Investment
aufteilt erfahrt ihr in diesem Video das
scheint fast so als hätte man in den
letzten Jahren auf dem Krypto und
Aktienmarkt nichts falsch machen können
naja mit ein paar Ausnahmen vielleicht
auf der Bank gibt's quasi keine Zinsen
die Rentenkasse scheint gerade für mich
als selbständigen jetzt nicht super
interessant zu sein also muss ich das
selber in die Hand nehmen damit ich
nicht in 10 Jahren wieder hier sitze und
euch nur vorlese was aus dem Geld hätte
werden können sondern das wirklich was
aus dem Geld geworden ist deswegen werde
ich heute endlich Geld investieren also
klar es ist nicht mein allererstes
Investment ich habe letztes Jahr viel
Geld im GameStop investiert damit viel
Geld gewonnen das war aber absolut
risikobehaftet würde ich niemandem
empfehlen und nachdem ich das gemacht
habe habe ich komplett erstmal mit
Aktien abgeschlossen weil ich komplett
durch war eine absolut schlimme Woche
für mich die Kursschwankungen zu sehen
und ich habe gemerkt hey ich habe
eigentlich überhaupt keine Ahnung davon
das waren kompletter Gamble und so soll
es nicht sein ich möchte Geld
langfristig investieren aber was habe
ich jetzt eigentlich geplant wo rein
möchte ich Geld investieren und vor
allem wie viel erstens ETF wer hätte es
gedacht der Standardweg für viele Leute
um dann Zinseszins über Jahrzehnte
hinwegvermögen aufzubauen zweitens
Krypto möglicherweise dicke Games
irgendwie die Zukunft aber irgendwie
auch nicht Krypto bzw die blockchain hat
super viele verschiedene
Anwendungsbereiche wir werden in diesem
Video aber rein wegen des Investments
kaufen und nicht wegen
Anwendungsmöglichkeiten oder Bereich
drittens Gold quasi der alte sehr weise
Mann den man vertrauen kann er als
sicherer Vermögens Erhalt gedacht und
weniger als Vermögensaufbau und Leist
but not least Luxus denn Luxus hat in
den letzten Jahren ordentlich an
Relevanz dazu gewonnen nicht zuletzt
weil es immer mehr reiche Leute bei
aktiven Handel mit Luxus kann man
ordentlich Vermögen aufbauen in unserem
Fall geht es aber um ein weiteres
Headset zum Wert er halt nach lange
überlegen und damit es für dieses Video
und für alle folgenden Videos aus dieser
Reihe wirklich das habe ich mich dafür
entschieden das superkrass zu streuen
das liegt zum einen daran dass ich gerne
Wert erhalten möchte da bin ich mir mit
der Rolex und dem Gold eigentlich
ziemlich sicher und bei den anderen
geht's ein bisschen mehr um Kurs
gewinnen ich möchte das alles abdecken
weil das eben für viele Leute die
Hauptsätze sind die interessant sind zum
investieren wir starten mit ETFs vorweg
allerdings noch eine Sache bei meinen
aktienvideos immer wieder gefragt
welchen Broker ich benutze und nachdem
ich mit meiner ersten Wahl nicht ganz so
zufrieden war wusste ich muss wechseln
und habe mich ein bisschen informiert
und bin zum finanzfluss-testsieger
scalable capital gekommen der jetzt
nicht nur mein fester Broker sondern
auch fester Partner ist scalable capital
ist ein Anbieter bei dem ihr direkt
übers Handy oder eine Desktop Version
super einfach in Aktien ETFs Krypto und
viele weitere Finanzprodukte investieren
Punkt die Account Eröffnung ist super
einfach direkt übers Handy möglich und
ihr könnt schon ab 1 € Aktien ETF und
krypto-sparpläne einrichten die Nutzung
unter counter-stellung ist komplett
kostenlos und mit einer Trading Flatrate
fallen die sogar eh schon gering oder
Gebühren von 99 Cent auch noch weg wenn
ihr also investieren wollt einen neuen
Broker sucht oder euch einfach mal mit
der App vertraut machen wollt klickt auf
klingt eine Videobeschreibung und macht
euch einen Account gelbe capital ist ein
deutsches Unternehmen aus München die
Baader Bank ist als Depotbank dahinter
auch eine Deutsche Bank auch aus München
das gibt mir ein super gutes Gefühl und
ich weiß dass sie in den richtigen
Händen bin nicht ohne Grund ist gelbe
capital der Testsieger im finanzfluss
Test das Video zum Broker Vergleich
findet ihr in der Videobeschreibung da
könnt ihr euch selber noch mal ein Bild
davon machen und ehrlich ich bin super
stolz gell will meinen Partner nennen zu
können deswegen auch hier noch mal ein
riesen Dank für das Vertrauen ans
komplettes gelbe Team check das aus
macht euch einen Account wir fangen
jetzt an zu investieren wir sind hier
schon in der App und ich habe in meiner
Watchlist schon die beiden ETFs die für
mich am interessantesten sind 70 30 ich
halte mich komplett an das finanzfluss
Prinzip und werde 70% in MSCI World und
30 % in MSCI immer den markets
investieren das ganze thesaurierend also
die Gewinner aus den Unternehmen die an
die Aktionäre ausgeschüttet werden
fließen sofort wieder in den ETF rein
das bedeutet ich kriege kein Geld
ausbezahlt sondern eine Position wird
mehr Wert oder meine Position wird
größer es fühlt sich unglaublich an so
viel Geld jetzt da drauf zu haben und zu
wissen dass es gleich investiert ist und
dann quasi in in besseren Händen ist als
auf der Bank rumzulegen wir klicken den
world an bei dem wir 7000 €, also 70 %
der 10.000 € die in die ETF esse Klasse
reinlaufen sollen investieren wollen und
möchten insgesamt für 7000 € 96
MSCI World Anteile kaufen
es fühlt sich so krass an und bevor wir
weitermachen mit MSCI imagine markets
will ich auch hier noch mal sagen ich
bin absolut kein Experte ich auf dem
Kanal von finanzfluss bekommt ihr
unglaublich gute sehr gut recherchierte
Informationen zu eigentlich fast jedem
finanzthema was ich interessieren kann
Check deswegen auf jeden Fall den Kanal
ab und außerdem investiert wirklich nur
mit Geld dass ihr absolut verlieren
könnt diese 40.000 € sind natürlich auch
für mich eine Menge Kohle ist aber Geld
was ich gerne langfristig investieren
möchte um irgendwie eine Altersvorsorge
zu haben um mich sicherer zu fühlen und
das Geld von der Bank wegzubekommen
kaufen hier für 3000 €
entgegengenommen tip top jetzt sehen wir
hier oben
29.994 € insgesamter Portfolio Wert ist
klar dass es am Anfang immer ein
bisschen schwankt und langfristig hoffe
natürlich dass es mehr wird 20.000 €
haben wir aber bis dato noch ohne
investiert weiter zur nächsten Kategorie
wir investieren in Gold und das ganze
nicht so dass wir hier zu einem
Goldhändler in Köln gehen und dort Gold
kaufen sondern das machen wir auch alles
über das gelbe kämpft warum das Ganze
wenn ich wirklich für 10.000 € physisch
Gold kaufen möchte dann habe ich
physisch Gold dann muss ich mich darum
kümmern nicht im Sinne von dass ich das
jetzt einmal im Monat putzen muss aber
es muss irgendwo liegen es muss im
besten Fall sichern und das ganze will
bezahlt werden ich wäre quasi darauf
angewiesen für das Gold ein
Bankschließfach zu kaufen um wirklich
absolute Sicherheit zu haben damit es
auch versichert ist und so weiter das
ganze kostet monatlich oder jährlich
aber Geld und das möchte ich nicht das
macht den Wert er halt von dem ganzen
dann vielleicht wieder weg gerade bei
10.000 € das ist jetzt nicht so ein
riesiger Betrag dass sich das quasi
refinanziert mit dem Bankschließfach das
Ganze zu Hause haben möchte ich aber
auch nicht deswegen ist es für die
schlauste Option das ganze einfach in
das gelbe App zu machen klicken wieder
auf kaufen und möchten 10000
die Order wurde angenommen
und quasi sofort ausgeführt sich so
verrückt an es fühlt sich crazy an aber
es fühlt sich auch richtig gut an weil
das Geld endlich nicht mehr auf der Bank
rumliegt und ich Angst haben muss dass
es von Tag zu Tag weniger wird oder ich
weiß dass es von Tag zu Tag weniger wird
deswegen bin ich super happy dass das
ganze jetzt passiert und wir machen
weiter mit der nächsten Kategorie jetzt
kommen wir zum Punkt auf den ich mich
nicht am meisten gefreut habe der aber
im aufregendsten für mich ist wir kommen
zu kryptowährung auf dieser Startseite
kann ich nämlich einfach direkt auf
kryptowährung wechseln und wir sehen
kryptowährungen die wir direkt in der
App kaufen können ich mache das ganze
direkt hier in scalable damit ich alles
an einem Fleck habe andere Leute würden
vielleicht auf anderen Plattformen das
direkt kaufen auf eine hardwolle ziehen
aber ich möchte den ganzen Stress nicht
haben ich möchte so einfach haben wie
möglich deswegen mache ich das direkt
hier und ich werde es endlich aufteilen
wie MSCI World und MSCI emergen markets
dafür starten wir mit Bitcoin das Gold
der kryptowährung wenn man das so sagen
kann relativ wenig Anwendungsbereiche
ist aber so dass Mutterschiff in diesem
ganzen Konstrukt deswegen bin ich
tatsächlich überzeugt dass es als
Investment langfristig Sinn überzeugt
davon dass es für mich Sinn macht wenn
jemand anderen wie gesagt ich bin kein
Experte wir klicken auf kaufen aktueller
Kurs sind
33.168 € 12% in der letzten Woche
gefallen ist gerade super volatil also
es geht super stark hoch super stark
runter wir kaufen für
7000 €
. ja oder wurde ausgeführt wir haben zu
einem Preis von
33174 € und 21 Cent 0,2 ein Bitcoin
gekauft wir machen weiter mit ethereum
und dann geht's ins Real Life denn ein
asset müssen wir wirklich tatsächlich in
Person kaufen wir wollen ausgeben
300082 €, das nämlich noch ziemlich
genau das was wir zur Verfügung haben
[Musik]
ich habe gerade 30.000 € von meinem
Handy aus investiert was ich völlig
verrückt anfühlt aber gleichzeitig auch
richtig gut ich habe richtig das Gefühl
dass es mir gerade so eine Last von der
Brust gefallen ist weil ich weiß dass
das Geld hier deutlich besser aufgehoben
ist als auf der Bank eine Sache können
wir aber tatsächlich nicht in der App
kaufen das ist auch gut so wir machen
uns auf dem Weg nach Düsseldorf bei wem
sollte ich die Uhr kaufen anders als dem
einzigen Warenmarkt Gebauer erhält schon
die Uhr in der Hand die nicht für mich
bestimmt ist sondern für einen von euch
ich bin ziemlich aufgeregt und freue
mich Dir jetzt zu sehen also tatsächlich
ist das deine ja okay dann habt ihr das
Video davor schon gesehen das hier ist
die Uhr die ich für mich gekauft habe
für genau dieses Projekt und was es für
eine ist das schauen wir uns jetzt an
das war auch meine erste Uhr ja also
eine Sache kann ich euch draußen sagen
ja heutzutage ähnlich wie bei Autos
jeder möchte immer neue neu haben aber
wenn ihr z.B vor mir sitzen wird und ihr
würdet so ein Modell sein aus den 19 und
80er Jahren tragen das zeigt immer dass
man sich ein bisschen damit mehr
auseinandergesetzt hat und es ist ein
sehr sehr spannendes Modell wir haben
hier eine submarine no date aber nicht
nur irgendeine sondern es ist eine two
Liner also hier drauf das ist quasi eine
read Edition von der 55 13 wir sehen
hier nur zwei Linien auf 6 Uhr
zusätzlich ist es so dass wir hier eine
spezielle Lünette verbaut haben und zwar
die also du hast wirklich tatsächlich
genau dieselbe die ich auch habe und
zwar Flat vor die vier hier auf der
Lünette ich weiß nicht ob du es erkennen
kannst die hat er Bild ein Trapez also
dieser mittlere Strich und oben das sind
so zwei Balken das nennt man fährt vor
und das ist so eine Tool watch modern
Wind also modern vintage hat schon
Saphirglas ist wirklich eine ja einfach
eine Alltagsuhr und ich sage immer
wieder wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste
für 1 Uhr ich dürfte nur eine Uhr tragen
wäre es immer diese hier und diese Uhr
kommt mit Box und Papieren wär mir toll
Lieferumfang alle buchlit sind mit dabei
ich habe knapp 12000 € bezahlt
knapp gehandelt so für 9 bis 95 und
jetzt in 12 Monaten hat sie einen guten
Sprung gemacht liegt auch daran dass die
Stückzahlen halt geringer sind waren
damals schon in neue 90er Jahren und die
Uhr wird sich auch so noch mal gut nach
oben entwickeln so habe ich also meine
ersten 40.000 € langfristig investiert
all diese Sachen will ich über Jahre
oder Jahrzehnte sogar halten und
tatsächlich soll es gar nicht dabei
bleiben tatsächlich soll die Verteilung
auch gar nicht so bleiben dass ich
gleich viel in Luxus investiert habe wie
in kryptow wie ein ETFs und so weiter im
Endeffekt soll es sich schon mehr
Richtung ETFs shiften aber für dieses
Video und für dieses Projekt finde ich
super interessant den gleichen Betrag in
verschiedene Assets oder verschiedene
Assetklassen investiert zu haben und das
über Zeit beobachten zu können das
bedeutet es wird vielleicht in 36 oder
12 Monaten mal ein Update Video geben
wie die Sachen performt haben
zwischendrin werde ich aber immer wenn
Geld da ist und ich mich wohl dabei
fühle weiter Geld zu investieren eher
Richtung ETFs gehen wir beobachten diese
10.000 oder 40 000 €, aber in Zukunft
weiter ich hoffe euch hat das Video
gefallen lasst mir eure Gedanken gerne
in den Kommentaren da und dann sehen wir
uns am Donnerstag schon wieder diese
Woche kommen drei Videos Donnerstag
weiter im büroumbau Sonntag tamed Doku
Klamotten Doku es wird richtig fett
endlich wieder bei contrak und jetzt
kommen wieder regelmäßig Videos
[Musik]